un mouvement de contestation de plus
large ampleur partie du prix du
carburant
ce matin les gilet jaune ont suivi
l'intervention d' emmanuel macron avec
de grandes attentes
les mouvements de samedi dernier
appelait une réponse de l'exécutif
les gilets jaunes ont eu le sentiment de
ne pas avoir été prises en compte
on est là mais il nous entend pas c'est
comme si on était inexistant pour moi
c'est un déni quelque part et justement
je pense que ça va le faire que
renforcer le mouvement des gilets jaunes
dans l'après midi un autre lieu de
passage tenus par des manifestants là
aussi l'occupation continue avec ses
habitudes et concernant l'allocution du
président c'est un rejet total et nous a
ignoré complètement complètement et nous
à hilard ya des sur nous rien sur le
gilet jaune
on est des milliers à des millions même
à vous pétez et où il ya personne qui a
parlé des gilets jaunes et pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi tout le temps pour les
riches
pourquoi pour les riches nous on n'a
rien on n'est rien on en a marre d'être
des vaches à lait on en a marre le
président macron a mandaté le ministre
de la transition écologique pour
recevoir les représentants des gilet
jaune
un geste d'ouverture là non plus cela ne
semble pas apaiser les manifestants
aient regardé deux minutes mais comme je
savais la ce qu'elle a à nous dire
il n'y aurait pas d' approche à ce qu'on
nous réclamations donc j'ai zappé
complètement ça ne va pas améliorer les
choses je pense pas content il va durcir
les mouvements la détermination des
gilet jaune demeure intacte il envisage
de poursuivre leur mouvement jusqu'aux
fêtes de fin d'année